disorienting Dreamscapes leather daddies
and a nod to A Christmas Carol the
ending of American Horror Story NYC is a
sad but hopeful culmination of a
harrowing season the first eight
episodes of American Horror Story NYC
focus more on mystery and crime than any
previous season of the show episode 8
Fire Island is a particularly
action-packed example the mai tai killer
is done and dusted but big daddy and Sam
are up to no good it all culminates in
what might be the end of Big Daddy and
the heartbreaking demise of Theo Graves
the final moments of the episode see the
show enter a dark Dreamscape from which
it never fully emerges this season's
final episodes Requiem 1981 1987 part 1
and Requiem 1981 1987 part 2 proceed to
dispense with anything resembling
dramatic tension instead closing the
show with trippy dream sequences that
bring the Ghost of Christmas fuchsia
from A Christmas Carol to mind these
dreams are far from sweet no one gets a
happy ending here even if they get a
living one and it's all a bit elliptical
cult but what the final episodes lack in
narrative Drive they make up for in
their steadfast commitment to portraying
the full Devastation and stigmatization
of the AIDS crisis
we want people to face what happened to
you American Horror Story NYC finishes
with a dream sequence dirge but it
starts as a sexy scary crime Thriller
audiences are kept guessing as to who or
what is killing Greenwich Village's gay
men and if Patrick Reed will figure out
the answer before the murderer sets his
sights on him as Patrick's actor Russell
Tove recounted to variety series
co-creator Ryan Murphy told him I've got
a great role for you it's going to be
based on cruising it's kind of like the
Al Pacino role as Savvy viewers might
know already this is a very intriguing
comparison that highlights one of the
finale's most important threads cruising
is a 1980 film starring Al Pacino as a
straight detective who goes undercover
as a gay man the film's debut is met
with controversy as the New York Times
reported it even inspired a March
through Greenwich Village gay rights
activist Ethan ghetto spoke for many
when he decried to the film's portrayal
of gay men and gay culture as
dangerously demeaning American Horror
Story NYC tackles the Legacy in a
complex way the fact that it isn't
written from a straight perspective
makes a big difference Patrick is a gay
man struggling with shame rather than an
undercover straight man it all comes
crashing down on him in the finale which
takes the season far from its more
straightforward Beginnings what results
is a fascinating continuation and
reversal of the Legacy left behind by
cruising
despair ties both halves of season 11
together and constitutes a main thread
of the final two episodes It's sorrowful
and rage-inducing to see Gino Borelli
write protest care taken ultimately
watch his loved ones die from AIDS the
fact that he does so in the face of poor
conditions in near total public
indifference makes things even more
intense Kathy Pizzazz the bath house
chantus slash tarotshop proprietor
laments to Adam Carpenter that the time
has come to close up shop saying all
that music
all that love
Freedom incarnate
Vitality Without Shame
but it's gone now
this sentiment is in contrast to the way
the series usually paints these spaces
this is after all a horror story and
though people have fun in these clubs
and bars they also suffer and die but in
this moment American Horror Story NYC
chooses to frame them as wonderful
places brimming with joy despite the
utter hopelessness and rage of The
Season's ending Kathy insists Adam
maintain hope and remember to live as
long as he's able
American Horror Story NYC is full of
sinister acts but it also explores
heart-rending passion and true love take
Geno and Patrick despite their hardships
their bond lasts all the way through the
devastation of Patrick's final days
together they move through shame to the
safety of their love this is at the core
of the Season as a whole and the finale
specifically one of the most powerful
moments of American Horror Story NYC
happens when Gino confronts Patrick
about sleeping with other men and being
into the leather scene which Patrick
previously claimed ignorance of
because you only tell the truth
when you're about to be caught that
that's shame Geno's words hit Patrick
and the audience Square in the chest for
all his strength and Swagger Patrick
needs to be challenged and comforted by
Gino Patrick's growth in turn forces
Gino to consider a truly wild
possibility hope when Geno Comforts
Patrick after an attempt on his life he
insists they're save
d
we're not 15
. there's a lot of sad truth to this
statement but it's not entirely accurate
in this moment these two find solace in
each other and that means everything in
fact in the world of American Horror
Story it's basically a miracle
the relationship between Adam and Theo
Graves is one of the most
of American Horror Story NYC it's sweet
sexy and healthy and because this is
American Horror Story it's not long for
this world Adam and Theo are something
of an Odd Couple the former is a square
satisfied with Knights Inn until he
dedicates his hours to searching for
lost friends and advocating for his
community the latter is creative drawn
to dark energy and finds Beauty in
surprising places Theo is also coming
off of Sam's manipulative machinations
which makes the steady energy between
him and Adam especially welcome but then
Adam and Theo are cruelly parted Adam
who has lost countless friends to
possibly the mai tai killer and
definitely Big Daddy now loses Theo to
Sam the biggest villain on the show who
isn't an allegory for illness Theo's
one-two punch of a demise via disease
drugs and possible sexual assault is the
traumatic cherry on top of an already
stuffed with trauma cake the final
episodes feature Theo and the role of
Sam's afterlife guide which serves as a
brutal reminder to the audience that the
good guys definitely don't always win
whether you think Patrick Reed is toxic
trash or a guy just doing his best one
thing is for sure no one deserves such a
rough death for all his brutality and
Bluster Patrick wants to stop the bad
guys even when he turns out to be one of
them thanks to Gino's good influence
Patrick goes from being a closeted cop
to an out gay man he still struggles
with shame and silence but hey it's
progress the fact that Patrick takes the
trophy for The Season's most improved
player makes his death especially
gutting what rubs even more salt in the
wound his afterlife guide is Barbara his
ex-wife who would have preferred Patrick
to continue living a lie she walks him
through the worst moments of his life
this begs a simple question why are we
to believe Patrick deserved his
suffering was he helpless to break the
cycle of pain did his own shame condemn
him to spend the afterlife reliving the
pain he caused and the pain the hateful
World caused him it's unclear and that
might be the point
shame
the lies the violence
to cycle Patrick Gino Borelli is one of
the good guys and boy is he mad about it
he's mad about everything actually and
with good reason not only is AIDS
devastating his community Gino is almost
murdered about a hundred times but Gino
just won't die for a while anyway he has
too much to do Geno appears in both
parts of requiem 1981 1987 and both
appearances are heartbreaking examples
of his tenacity in the face of
Relentless ignorance and cruelty they're
also proof of his deep and unending love
his tenderness towards Patrick and his
poor excuse for a hospital room is
particularly Vivid he's not at his
typewriter or a protest site but Gino's
care is just as passionate and committed
this man's Home Fires are fueled by love
and rage and he keeps both burning until
The Bitter End
Sam is the embodiment of
self-centeredness and a horrifying
example of just how Reckless and
Ruthless People can be when they only
care about what they want though he's
not technically a serial killer Sam does
the dirtiest Deeds on all of American
Horror Story NYC I am really sorry that
I forgot my violin for this perfect
little moment but we do have a body to
dispose of so you want to pitch in it in
other words Sam is a capital V villain
and the finale plays with this fact in
fascinatingly disorienting ways Requiem
1981 1987 part 1 is largely dedicated to
Theo's Spirit guiding Sam through the
terrible acts he committed in life as
well as a very creepy interlude with
Sam's father who caused him significant
pain this episode is disorienting due to
its dreamlike nature such an approach
paired with a deeper look into Sam's
psyche packs a significant punch while
this might seem like a jarring switch of
Storytelling and perspective the sheer
amount of time the audience is forced to
spend in Sam's nightmare ends up working
we see a different side of Sam mere
moments before he makes out with his own
personal Big Daddy and catches a ride to
the flip side does it redeem him not
really but it forces us into a new point
of view
if American Horror Story NYC is
successful at anything it's making
audiences understand that great pain
shame and desire Drive drastic actions
the final episodes of American Horror
Story NYC are a festival of death and
not just the slasher kind the slow
silent March into Oblivion is evidenced
by countless skull masked men dropping
into an open grave and Geno living out
his final days under Big Daddy's
impenetrable leather-clad gaze while
this imagery is devastating poetic and
nearly overwhelming it might also feel a
bit confused to some viewers why they
might wonder is the scepter of death a
leather daddy what's the real world
meaning of this complicated symbol the
leather scene is important to the
community captured in American Horror
Story NYC it's also full of pain making
big daddy the Avatar of the AIDS crisis
can be seen as underscoring many points
he is a terrible perversion of community
Joy a symbol of the Public's callousness
and cruelty towards gay men and a
complicated mingling of anger and
despair Big Daddy's ending points
towards deeper shame still being teased
out and resolved in the aftermath of the
AIDS crisis it's up to interpretation
but one thing is clear big daddy is key
to the ending's meaning
Adam Carpenter is the closest thing
American Horror Story has to a Beacon of
Hope so it's a good thing he's the last
man standing yet Adam still endures
unspeakable heartbreak he loses his
lover many friends and experiences the
trauma of the big daddy and my Thai
killer attacks undaunted Adam moves
through his losses this momentum is key
to the season's ending if Geno creates
his own Sentinel Persona using love loss
and rage's fuel Adam builds his
protector Persona out of a dedication to
and deep understanding of his community
he may look like a Boy Scout but by the
time the finale rolls around we know
he's lived through hell Adam's concerns
about AIDS are consistently dismissed
yet he still fights the good Public
Health fight it doesn't stop him and it
also doesn't break him much lip service
is paid to the importance of
transcending cycles of pain and
protecting one's community in the final
episodes of American Horror Story NYC
Adam is shown doing just this by the
time Adam stands to speak at Geno's
funeral we see him open his mouth take a
breath and that's it we don't need more
because his act actions speak for
themselves we already know that whatever
Adam has to say will provide his
community with a much needed bit of
light in the unrelenting dark
[Music]